hey everybody and welcome to a crazy
wild ride with stevo this episode's
loaded with so many shocking bombshells
i don't know how else to describe it but
crazy and speaking of crazy i
just recently got connected with a new
sponsor for this show called better help
and they are an online way of finding
therapists and you know what i needed to
get into therapy i knew i needed to get
into therapy and thanks to better help i
did get into therapy and it was so easy
to do it online without having to get
into some awkward waiting room and
without having to get in the car and
drive anywhere i mean dude this little
questionnaire they had me fill out
really zeroed in very specifically on
what it is i wanted to work on and their
humongous network of licensed
professional accredited therapists is
just
they're really good at syncing people up
with the people who are best suited to
help them and yeah i just had my first
session i'm thrilled with it i'm
absolutely thrilled with it plus this
whole service is so convenient and
affordable and i can get you ten percent
off your first month so if you go to
betterhelp.com
stevo you're gonna get 10 percent off
your first month of what is already
so affordable and professional therapy
it's good for your mental health i want
you to be a happier healthier person and
it's okay to work on yourself man i do
it and i'm better for it too so go to
betterhelp.com
stevo and get 10 off of this whole
therapy thing which i'm sure you've
heard helps people and it can help you i
believe that so
enjoy be happier be healthier
betterhelp h-e-l-p-dot-com
stevo
now let's get into it do you smoke i
don't smoke weed now no cigarettes
cigarettes now
she's like that naturally yeah
he went to a doctor the guy was like you
just suck at talking like he just like
strains his throat muscles when he talks
really
is that it but it wasn't always like
that right um it it's gotten a little
crazier over time yeah yeah
all right
let's go man
yeah by all means
all right here we go
ladies and gentlemen corey feldman
what's up
yeah dude you've met scott randolph
scott yes sitting here so nice and
intimately with you yeah
the gorgeous paul briskey howdy corey
how are you paul i'm great man thank you
gotta say i'm super excited about this
me too man me too it's a wild ride yeah
that's weird no dude i've uh i've
watched your stuff for many years and
all the crazy
nutty stuff you've done right yeah man
and you guys haven't you ran into each
other before yeah i feel like we like
kind of met somewhere but never really
like talked talked right yeah i think we
met at the playboy mansion i want to say
yeah what year which i mean that would
have been surprised me i think early
like maybe like 2002 or something oh wow
how many times have you been to the
playboy mansion
and i got kicked out
i forgot i forget why i was kicked out
probably running around naked jumping in
the grotto i think it was more of a
cocaine thing oh really yeah i think i
was like caught you doing drugs i think
i was doing cocaine like really
blatantly out in the open right
and they're like there's bathrooms for
that
there's cocaine room for that
of hard drugs right he was pretty anti
hard drugs from what i remember yeah you
never saw him touch anything really but
for sure you know he was definitely he
was a fan of the quaaludes i think that
was kind of well known you know you hear
lots of stories that he had his special
doctor that took care of special needs
you know how do you get invited to the
playboy mansion is it like a letter or a
phone call yes steve how'd you get
invited i can't remember
i think i actually do remember
and that it was
uh it came through like the jackass
channels okay there was like the jackass
guys
somebody probably around the time where
the movies came out and they got you up
there is like hey he's got a new movie
out let's get him up here it'll be wacky
and zany watch him create all kinds of
problems and they're like oh yeah
that'll be fun oh wait his problem is
actually doing cocaine on the front lawn
no we can't have that yeah yeah
we didn't realize he was coming in
character
how many times have you been there
three thousand
like i was there every weekend oh really
wow that's epic at how starting at how
young and was word these are like post
dated because there's no more playboy
mansion yeah what is it what is the
place it's not just a mansion a museum
without the playboy
without that it's not even that it
should have been that if they were smart
that's what they would have done they
would have preserved it but instead some
dude took it over bought it and like
literally like changed it all like how
do you go and deface a historical
monument like
to why why
story
i remember the story was
that heff sold it
while he was still alive yes but the
deal was that the guy had to keep it the
way it was until half died not only that
but have had the right to live in it
until he died so what that did was force
the people who had basically
taken over the company and taken over
all of his stuff to try and like make
him as uncomfortable and miserable as
possible while he was still there so
they were doing stuff like telling them
like you can no longer have you know
your guests over in the parking you can
never no longer have the parking guys do
your parking for you you can no longer
have your poker nights or your movie
nights or whatever these guests aren't
allowed anymore you know whatever they
would just like take away all of his
freedoms to the point where he felt so
like isolated and miserable that he
didn't even want to live and i think
that's kind of sadly that's that's kind
of how it went down wow damn yeah and he
sold it because like financially he just
couldn't personally keep it up yeah so
basically what happened was you know and
i don't want to go too deep but there
was a uh let's say a buyout
uh with a certain company because he was
in a lot of trouble say around 2007 2008
right around the time right after we
shot up there actually we did the two
cory's shoot up there my ex-wife
where are we shot in the uh
right right not where we where we shot
up there no yeah yeah
we weren't shooting up there but we were
shooting up there up there
uh yeah no so we so we were shooting for
the two coreys and and uh and have
asked my ex-wife susie to be in the
magazine on the show and that was part
of it and i got to actually direct heff
which was really cool wow because you
know
all the other show runners were like
scared to touch it like
we don't want to talk to the guy what
are we gonna say i'm like don't worry i
got this you know i mean so i was like
okay here's what we need you to do
and he was great he was very helpful
very cool very cooperative um and yeah
he asked in a very kind of amazing way
like it's so cool to have that footage
of i mean i'm not her so i wasn't really
asked to be in it but
to be her
you know he like sits her down at the
dinner table which we've sat at with him
a thousand times you know it's like
where he would like have the dinner in
between the movie do you ever go for a
movie night on a sunday oh yeah kind of
like that's more like the casual chill
like only really close
right right right but you would have
been you know if you didn't screw up and
do play
anyway um so so that's kind of how it
happened for me i mean i went up to one
of the big parties you know and then
like five years later i was invited back
for a movie night and then like once i
went to a few of the movie nights
eventually i was invited to come sunday
during the afternoon by ron smith
and when i went in the afternoon a
couple times half liked me you know he
saw me around and he was like hey you
know what
you're a cool guy i was like thanks he's
like if you want to come on fridays or
saturdays anytime you're welcome anytime
on the weekends you're welcome so my
name was added to the permanent list so
basically i didn't have to get clearance
i could bring whatever girls i want
unless it was a big party where you
still had to get you know
whatever authorized for your guests but
um but yeah i was like on the permanent
list so any friday saturday sunday if i
wanted to come up if i wanted to bring
three girls four girls it didn't matter
i would just show up and and roll up to
the gate and they would let me in so and
you said that you were married at that
time i was married at that time yes so
was it your inclination to be married
and bring three or four girls no no no
this was not then oh gotcha right i'm
saying that's where my status was and
then once i got divorced then yes i was
up there quite frequently with a lot of
guests three or four girls man that's
pretty fun for somebody that's never
been
for somebody's never been like what's a
party at the playboy mansion here was my
whole theory my old theory was i didn't
want to
bring i i didn't a lot of people say we
don't want to bring sam to the beach
right right i didn't want to take sand
from the beach
i didn't want to be that guy you know
what i mean like because i knew that if
i was then i wouldn't be invited back
very often you know i liked my status
and i knew that my status was there
because half saw that i respected the
boundary you know i mean it's all about
respecting the boundary he's the host
these are his girlfriends stay away from
his girls you know very simple i enjoyed
going up seeing my friends i had like a
second family up there so i enjoyed
seeing all of you know the people that
you see every week it was like a weekly
group and everybody got together we
watched movies we had fun we had laughs
stay away from his girls so were you
like i bring my own girls
super careful to bring like the hottest
chicks of course yeah but i mean that's
i don't date anything other than that
anyway right you know
seriously like i'm just i have very very
very high standards like always have and
like detrimentally so because those are
the girls that screw with your head the
most of course you know the hotter they
are the more they're going to screw with
you right but whatever i was willing to
take that you know i love that
risk you were willing to take i love
that big one for the team i love that
and i love even more your candor about
that yeah just to say hey man like hot
chicks right i mean that was my deal i
just you know when i was a single guy
i'm like i first and it's not because i
like i love everybody i love i love
people i love humans i love my fans
whether they're big fat skinny small
tiny
rounds thin it doesn't matter you know i
love them equally and i find beauty in
everybody so unless they're just a total
dick bag and then if they have them
there's no beauty there but you know his
slum buster's like a prague model you
know
but you know for me it's like it's like
if i'm gonna have to be with that person
and wake up every day to them and be
excited about it then you know it's got
to be really really good because
otherwise there's going to be three or
four more running around the corner
they're going to be like cory come here
this way
cool so it's interesting man yeah and
being famous then in like the 80s and
90s is a totally different world even
you're like oh no not then i'm talking
now oh yeah oh here we go i'm talking
like in the last ten years nice because
because no in the 80s and 90s i was shy
and awkward
didn't really date now you've hit your
stride
well in between okay let's let's back it
up so between my first marriage and my
second marriage i i had a lot of growth
between my second and my third marriage
i had a lot of growth and by growth i
mean boners
that was awesome
no
but yeah
no what i meant was that like i had a
growth meaning like self appreciation or
or feeling the value of my own worth
right like whereas because like i was
very shy i was very awkward and i was
very insecure because i was made to
believe i was fat and ugly my whole life
i was beat up by kids at school i was
beat up by my mom i was always bullied
so like i was told i was fat and i was
ugly and i believed that up until i was
35 years old man i was very insecure i
mean i know that when you're a hugely
successful
child star yeah which you were i mean
right like
so
i know that when you're in a school
system and you're the big child star
that there's actually like a bullying
component right even though you have
like insane amounts of power or
popularity or whatever
you're playing you're not in school
you're a celebrity yeah but so it's a
different ballgame you're like the
you're you're the dumb kid because you
leave all the time you're the stupid kid
right you know and you must think you're
special because you get to like not be
here when the rest of us have to slave
away at school all day that's the way
they looked at it it's pretty it's
pretty incredible to me that that uh
you can be bullied in that kind of
situation but then what what
what else to to be
made to believe that you're fat
when you were never fat i was a little
bit chubby like i had like what movie
were you fattest in
um i would say it wasn't like maybe a
movie but i think definitely on the bad
news bears tv series i mean i got a big
round of applause for the [ __ ] 70s
yeah i was seven and eight years old
yeah but this is called screwed up in
the head
you know your mom tells you you're fat
you think you're fat i wasn't allowed to
eat in those days she would literally
keep meals from me or like hide the you
know candy and the junk food because i
wasn't allowed to eat it
um so that was then right then even all
the way up until gremlins like look at
me and grandma's i'm filling out those
those pants pretty tight you know i got
like a chubby face i got the little bit
of a belly there gremlins was uh like
84. i was like 83. oh 83 i was shooting
it yeah 83 i was shooting it it came out
in 84.85 and then goonies we shot in 84
and it came out in 85 right right okay
yeah so by goonies i started to lose a
little bit of it and then by standby and
i mean
okay came into my were you already doing
coke on standby no no no no no no
no i was like those gremlins dude
no no no no that that didn't start till
ladies and gentlemen be warned we are
about to discuss powder cocaine and i
cannot be more grateful for having given
up
that kind of powder for a new kind of
powder called athletic greens
man this is the one stop shop for all of
my supplement needs man if you want to
wake up in the morning and take a lot of
supplements on an empty stomach that's
real bad for you plus who knows if
they're any good athletic greens i wake
up and i dump one of my travel packets
or a scoop from my big jar
right into a pint of water it is
absolutely delicious it's totally okay
on a completely empty stomach it fills
in all of my nutrition gaps and trust me
i do have nutrition gaps i don't always
eat that well but with athletic greens
i'm getting all of the nutrients all the
vitamins everything i need and it's
really good for my gut and my digestion
i mean dude this is the best stuff and i
use it every single morning religiously
and i got a funny feeling that
you could use it you know
big time it's sourced from all whole
foods it's all just
good quality stuff and again absolutely
delicious if you go to
athleticgreens.com
stevo then you're going to get an entire
year's supply of immune boosting vitamin
d plus five of these travel packets and
dude i don't go anywhere without my
travel packets of ag-1
yeah so let's get you on this man go to
athleticgreens.com
stevo for an entire year's supply of
immune boosting vitamin d and five free
travel packets of ag-1 and just watch
see how much better you feel how quickly
you do man i stand by that product i use
it every day i love it i love it i love
it and now let's talk about a much worse
powder
okay so the first time i did cocaine was
because my mom was doing it with
somebody on the set of the lost boys
okay this little hot little asian woman
who i was sitting there one night
because i was like falling asleep and i
was depressed because i'm like how the
hell am i gonna stay for these night
shoots i've never done a night shoot i
mean i've done like the friday 13th
night shoots but that was like we come
in at noon we work until midnight and
then you go home because like when
you're a kid they're only going to let
you work so late and then they're going
to call it but like now
i'm still a kid but i'm 14 years old 15
years old you know when when you get to
those ages all of a sudden they start
treating you more like you're an adult
right and the work code still applies
but they'll be like oh we're gonna do
like a half day half night so we're
coming in at three in the afternoon and
we'll work until three in the morning
and i was like wait what
i i wasn't very good at that
so
i was a little frustrated like how am i
gonna do this how am i gonna stay up all
night and this little asian lady comes
up to me and she's like hey you should
just do what your mom does to stay awake
and i was like what's that and she's
like cocaine and i was like
uh okay
i wouldn't really know where to go she's
like oh i have it just come to my
apartment we'll do something it'll be
easy and then you'll be fine i was like
oh okay well she makes it sound so easy
and harmless i might as well if my mom's
doing it how bad could it be you know
how old were you uh i was like i said 15
15. yeah when was the first time you did
coke how old were you oh [ __ ] i didn't
do coke until i was
uh
20 i think
yeah late bloomer experience i did it on
my high school lunch break
my senior year or something like come
over and i did oh it's bad so i got okay
so the first time i did it sorry it's a
bad experience
because it was it was it was good at
first like we did it we had fun it was
like you know we were talking we're
sitting in this girl's apartment she
takes me out driving she taught me how
to drive a stick shift high on cocaine
for the first time um jones and then and
then you know here's the thing i did one
line and i thought that one line was
gonna last forever we're gonna live
forever you know so that's what i was
thinking at the moment fame um but what
happened was unfortunately i was wrong
and it did not and so i didn't go to
sleep in between when i that whole thing
which was like say six to 12 in the
afternoon and then at 12 i go out with
my friend for the day and then i've got
like a four o'clock call and i never
slept anywhere in between and i've got
to work from four to four and so then i
say to the girl like hey you know what i
have a feeling this stuff might wear off
uh how long does it take to wear if
she's like oh it'll be worn off by the
time you go into work and i'm like well
i'm gonna probably need more than to
keep me up she's like don't worry i'll
meet you there i'll give you some more
well that was my first lesson and people
doing drugs are not very honest
so yeah found out the hard way that she
was full of it and uh waited for her to
show up she didn't show up she didn't
show up she flaked on me she left me
hanging right and so i'm sitting there
like you know showing up for work
getting my costume on like half asleep
like okay i gotta make it through this
she'll be here any minute it's cool and
i'm like calling her texting her i don't
think we had text in those days that's a
lie i was just calling her um
yeah and she didn't show up like no
response no anything you know i'm
sending a birdie over to her house
um and so she doesn't show up she leaves
me hanging and it's now like eight
o'clock at night and we're shooting the
very first scene that day which happens
to be hold for it wait for it yeah the
big truth justice in the american way
speech scene that everybody remembers
that moment was during this hell so it
was literally at that moment where i'm
like and joel schumacher's like okay so
you're gonna come to this spot you're
gonna stop here you're gonna pause for
two seconds you're gonna deliver the
first part of the line then you're gonna
wait and cory's gonna clear over here
and then jamison's gonna come over to
this point and then when he stops you're
gonna open the magazine you're gonna
look at it you're gonna pull it down to
right here and then you're gonna look
over the top i mean like all these
instructions i'm like
no dude are you dead i did not pull it i
didn't it was it was a disastrous
meltdown was it was it clear to anybody
that the drugs were involved here's what
was clear i'm a guy that's very on my
[ __ ] all the time i'm very efficient i'm
very like i try to stay
you know i'm a professional i study the
night before i get all into my
memorization i come in the next day i
know my stuff backwards and forwards you
know impeccable i'm a professional i
don't mess around but all of a sudden i
couldn't remember one thing to the next
that he's telling me to do
and he's looking at me like what is
wrong with you like dude i just said
three times here's the order of the
thing and you just you know i say come
to this mark stop you know freeze turn
around lower the thing and then say your
line you're going over here you're
walking past your mark you're not
lowering the thing you're saying you're
lying without even looking at the place
you're supposed to look i'm like uh
okay let's do it again so that happens
like 10 times and eventually joel
schumacher's like okay i don't know
what's wrong with you are you on drugs
are you on drugs feldman is that what's
going on here like totally called me out
and i was like huh i wish i was on drugs
i wouldn't be so screwed up right now no
so so yeah that was the problem i had no
drugs um so he knew there was something
going on and he fired this was at a time
when uh
when everything was still shot on film
oh absolutely yeah it was all filming so
to screw up a take was actually kind of
expensive at that time very expensive
yeah and uh you said he fired you yeah
he fired me he fired me right there on
the spot he's like listen fellman i
don't know what's going on with you but
you're fired you need to get your act
together i can't have this on my set i
don't know what's going on but you're
you know coming in all out of it looking
like you're high
duh-duh-duh-duh-duh-duh-duh-duh like
for like two hours
but what happened was they were like
look the only way we're gonna let you
continue is if you get some where's your
mom that was the first question where's
your mom why is she not here why are you
all out of it somebody needs to answer
for this
and i was like um good luck finding her
she's probably off with some crew member
in the bar
wow you know doing
drunk getting laid who knows and so
they couldn't find her they all did like
an apb to try and find my mom nobody
could find her they're like this is a
disaster and then they're like well we
can't really blame it on the kid if he's
got no adult supervision so we've got to
at least give him a chance by like
saying okay you've got to have like some
adult supervision around right and then
if you still mess up then we'll fire you
for real so they decided to see like is
your dad available can your dad come
down my dad couldn't come down because
he had his talent management company
which was basically like a false
management company where it was like
like like the powers remember jg powers
or whatever like where they'd like take
your money and do seminars and like
they'd pick like 100 people to like oh
yeah you're the best looking one so
you're gonna get a free photo shoot but
everybody else has got to pay fifteen
thousand dollars for that same photo
shoot in an acting class and maybe one
day you'll get an acting part and that
was kind of like his thing but he had my
movie posters up all over the walls and
it was called new talent enterprises and
it was like over on the sleazy part of
kawenga there
anyway
so
he was doing that and he didn't have
time to come play babysitter so he says
no i'm not available so they were like
well who can you get up here and that we
called marty weiss and marty weiss was a
guy who had been kidnapping me since i
was 11 years old
he was part of the science fiction
awards or whatever it was called the
saturn
he was not my agent he was literally
just like a stalker hangar on dude that
basically got into my life because he
worked for the saturn awards and was
trying to give me an award so he like
called me up but comes to find out that
he basically gave awards to all of like
or like got in touch with all the steven
spielberg kids so i thought he was just
a big steven spielberg fan big disney
fan he loved all those kids he was he
introduced me to another kid that became
one of my best friends at the time named
jason preston who was in explorers i
don't know if you remember the movie
explorers with uh ethan hawk and river
phoenix but okay yeah that was a joe
dante movie um steven spielberg movie as
well but anyway so so he became friends
with him and then introduced me to him
and he became my best friend up until i
met corey haim a couple years later so
from like gremlins to lost boys this kid
jason president was my best friend so
anyway come to find out that this guy's
like molesting everybody and so he's a
pedophile and
then we find out that basically well he
comes in it's in you know my book and in
my movie and whatever i want to get into
the graphic stories but let's just say
that he took advantage of the situation
okay
and at that time this was the set of
lost boys so you are 14
turning 15. turning 15. and like so
incredibly famously at the age of 15
you started the emancipation right so
what happened was like so i okay since
marty it wasn't because marty was there
it was because i was embarrassed and i
was shamed that i went down that road
and i did drugs at all because i was so
anti-drug normally like why did i do
that drugs aside there was like
financial [ __ ] going on all kinds of
[ __ ] yeah but the bottom line was i was
just like dude my life sucks right now i
need to like try and keep this job
because otherwise i'm screwed this is my
only chance of like staying away from
that abusive household you know so
especially now that they realize my
mom's the bad guy like that's the best
news really out of all this is that i
have a chance to get away from my mom
because she was really wretched and your
parents were together they were not
together not together so that was the
point was like right if my dad was gonna
at any point come in and kind of save
the day because at least i knew with him
you know we'd smoke weed together and he
wouldn't kick my ass you know i mean my
mom was just like psycho wanted to beat
me all the time wanted to abuse me he
wanted to do whatever she could to just
like hard drugs and physical violence or
versus everything's pretty cool right
he's a musician and like you know like
probably hit on all my girlfriends but
whatever you know this sort of thing um
so i went to the dad but that was after
we got back from santa cruz so once we
got back from santa cruz then my dad
says hey here's a great idea let's get
you involved in this thing called
hollywood kids say no to drugs and
you'll be like the spokesperson because
we know you hate drugs and i'm like
perfect so i start doing that then he
introduces me to pedophile number two
um well actually i'd already met
pedophile number two which was alfie but
he came through
the whole because i knew him from being
supposedly bobby hoffman's son bobby
hoffman was the head of casting for
paramount television and cast me on all
of my tv shows growing up as a kid and
many other kids as well and then he was
living with this dude alfie and alfie
started doing these underage clubs
called alfie's soda pop club so that's
when my mom invited me to go
to alfie's club or whatever his party
with bobby at their house and he's like
out and she's like alfie's gonna come
pick you up so you're very special
you're very lucky because alfie's gonna
come pick you up and take you to this
party so alfie was one then john but
john comes through my dad and so my dad
over at new talent is like hey uh i
can't be on the set with you during lost
boys all the time and i'm really busy
and stuff so i'm gonna get you this
assistant guy who's basically gonna
drive you around and be your gopher and
be your chaperone and beer whatever
because again right the whole reason
joel schumacher wanted to get me
parental guidance and wanted to like
make sure that i was set before he kept
me on board was to make sure that i
didn't get around some flunky who wasn't
going to take it seriously and wasn't
gonna care about my best interest right
well so what does my dad do i go to my
dad's for better care and end up with a
new flunky who's also a pedophile isn't
that ironic like every time i get
swapped to somebody it's like another
pedophile so anyway yeah that's how
everybody keeping it in
who are you gonna tell yeah i mean your
parents are the ones that are bringing
them into your life right and by by the
way um nothing happened with the alfie
guy until after i was living with my dad
so when i was living with my mom the
only thing that was happening was that
marty weiss was coming and breaking me
out of my house in the middle of the
night and taking me out on drives but he
never molested me during that time he
was only kidnapping me and we were
having fun together so it didn't look
like anything i would see that's the
thing that's how they get you right they
get your trust by like grooming you
right by being your friend and being
like hey i'm gonna be the cool guy
that's gonna get you out of this bad
situation so then you trust them so how
does the emancipation
course how do we get there
so ironically it's the guy
that
was hired by my dad john grissom who is
the pedophile who says hey you got to
get away from these abusive parents
and they're taking all your money and
they're screwing you over we got to get
you out of this situation chuck went up
for the pedophile because that was a
good call right so he's like so we'll
get you in was it though really who
knows that's the thing
then he also introduced me to cocaine
because like after that so now that i'm
with him it's like we're hanging out all
the time like oh look at sam kinnison
all these guys at the comedy store
they're like love you let's go hang out
with them and then we walk into their
parties and there's giant mounds of
cocaine on the table 15 year olds should
not have been there in the first place
but he walks me in he's like hey man
this is a party and i'm like cool it's a
party and then like i'm like but i don't
do cocaine and i resisted it for like
the first six months hanging out with
all those guys and then eventually i
just got weak and i was like well they
look like they're all having fun and if
they're having fun i guess they weren't
having a pretty good time at the comedy
store they were and they were yeah that
was before they crossed the imaginary
line so it was all good in the show you
know and is that when kennison had the
house like right up the hill from the
comedy store crystal that's it so we
were chilling at crystal so anyway so it
was at the crest hill house actually
where i did my first like not the one
for my mom which was the one time one
line but this was like the first time i
actually did did cocaine okay so john
grissom gives it to me and he's like
oh you gotta trust now you gotta try
crack now you gotta try heroin now you
gotta try lsd so every drug that i ever
did literally was because of the same
dude okay how soon after did you start
doing heroin oh like two years later two
years it was a process but i had to go
through my cocaine phase like where i
got really into coke for a while that
was like the whole thing lasted two
years but like basically i was really
into cocaine for like six months to a
year
and then
was like you know i see it destroying
all my friends lives i see it destroying
my life i cross that imaginary line
people are having that talk with me
they're like you don't see you have a
problem you have a problem i'm like what
is the problem i'm staying up for three
four days at a time and we're having a
great time no problem you know they're
like no that's a problem
that is the problem right that pedophile
didn't do everything
to help but
he was the one who said you got to get
away from your parents so i can have
more control over you and right
along with you and put you on drugs so i
can completely manipulate and control
thanks
but it wasn't like some superhero right
right but did he did he get you set up
with some kind of attorney because yeah
i was fascinated by the idea yeah
like the idea and the journey
like that the uh
because you were like the first like
child star to legally
like become independent of your parents
before like when you're only 15 years
old that's not the first i believe
drew did it first audrey barrymore she
might have done it first okay so we're
right neck and neck around the same
right yeah i mean it's a pretty big deal
and and and what i read about it
was that you were a bona fide
millionaire at 15 years old but by the
time the court proceedings played out
like all they had to show for all of
your earnings was forty thousand dollars
you got your you did your fact check out
that very well done
so well let me tell you how it actually
went down i was really fascinated to ask
this question because to become
emancipated from your parents means to
become completely independent of them he
did this at the age of 15
and was like wow you know okay i got no
parents i'm an adult that's fascinating
and you know what else is fascinating
being completely independent of having
to get in your car and drive anywhere if
you want to get food if you want to get
groceries if you want to get any
household supplies you know what
stay put do what you got to do leave it
to door dash man this is the best way to
get food fresh
everything delivered and here's a killer
deal for you you download the door dash
app you plug in the promo code stevo for
your first order of over 15 bucks you
get 25
off and no delivery fees boom and that's
good for a value of up to ten dollars so
go ahead and figure out what do you want
to eat maybe something from your
favorite restaurant
let your imagination run wild then
download the door dash app plug in the
promo code stevo and like i said enjoy
25 off of your first order of 15 or more
a value of up to 10 dollars and zero
delivery fees so get your work done let
it just come to your door enjoy and
let's try to figure out what's going on
with this emancipation business
so so basically what happened was
in order to get emancipated i had to be
on my [ __ ] like i had to know what i was
doing i had to be able to like say okay
this is
right because otherwise they're not
going to let you go they want to see a
that you know what you're talking about
you know your finances you know where
you're at and that you're going to be
able to be self-sufficient and provide
for yourself
in the event that they turn over the
power of signature to you right so
um basically what happened was i went
down to the producer's pension health
and welfare which is where everybody
who's an actor their residuals go their
payment their you know futures their
pension it's all put into there so
there's an accounting it's not part of
sag it's a separate division separate
building are you a producer i was not no
no no it's the producers pension health
and welfare meaning the producers have
to pay into this pension
for the on the behalf of the actors
right okay so there's a certain amount
of money that accrues so they can a see
all the money that you've earned and
then b see what's left in your accounts
because they're the ones that make sure
that like with the jackie coogan law
they have to put like 15 percent aside
from every paycheck that keeps coming up
it's crazy your parents are only allowed
to blow 85 of your money right exactly
but we're gonna make sure you got a few
cents left don't worry
and that's what is not covered up right
because the way my parents did it which
was super slick because typically like a
manager gets 10 to 15 as you know right
well my my parents were both my managers
and they both took 15 wow so there's
your 30 right there off the top then you
got 40 to taxes i don't know about like
literary then you got your business
manager your agent your agent takes ten
percent business manager takes five
percent wait what's happened where
there's fifteen percent how do they
justify fifteen percent because they
figure they're taking off of words right
that is a bit too much why should those
kids earn anything screw those kids
why wouldn't it be like uh why not 100
percent or like no no
it should be yeah yeah kids should get
all the money yeah it should be 85 to
the kid and like
between all the managers right because
kids are doing the work right do they
figure because like their childhood
giving up their freedom
yeah somebody go ahead what's even more
crazy i mean we could talk about the
unfairness of uh
all the all the money being the
commissions but but it's just so
fascinating to me a judge grants you
emancipation and so now you're 15 years
old but you are not legally an adult
right
waving the idea of minor so here's what
happens so we go to the court right and
i prove okay so this is where that comes
in we go to producers pension health and
welfare they show me you have earned a
million dollars to this point at 14 and
a half this is where you're at you've
earned a million dollars however
here's what's in your account right now
and that's where the forty thousand
right i mean you gotta figure if you've
earned a million then that puts you in a
pretty high tax bracket so you can
almost ballpark it at 50 percent goes to
taxes until it fits down 15 year old
right you know yeah so there's [ __ ]
going on but it wasn't necessarily like
as crazy as a million down to 40 000
yeah it's pretty
[Music]
resume at that time you know like with
with goonies kremlin's last boys like
friday the 13th right [ __ ] all the
madam speakers bad news all of it morgan
mindy with robin williams all of it
it's it feels pretty shocking that you
would only have earned a million dollars
at that point well yeah because they
weren't paying people like they were
these days right like there was no
backhand there was no
no stand by me
do you know what i got paid i'll tell
everybody i got paid for goonies forty
thousand dollars it was that sag scale
for a principal role yeah because we
were on it for six months and all that
that's forty thousand dollars for six
months later crazy right that's like
slave labor if you think about it and
we're almost where the [ __ ] we're almost
40 years later and and now sag scale for
that kind of rolls 65 grand right
exactly
but that said if you do one movie you
get jumped up to like the million dollar
tax day i mean payday bracket you know
what i mean like you do one movie that's
successful you're getting an offer from
me yeah the kids inspired 15 number one
films and we're still getting like here
license to drive how about a hundred
thousand dollars and i'm like what it's
my name over the damn title and that's
the kind of money we were making it was
terrible it was terrible could you
negotiate were you like told not to do
that or i mean what do you um my my
agents were like william morris at the
time so yeah they probably should have
made sure that that didn't happen right
you would think
here's a question i was dying to to ask
you because
you know i'm known for for all the
jackass stuff you are but i'm just
joking
right but but i've since really like
established myself in the comedy world
during stand-up
and i'm still not known as a stand-up
comedian but i've been
like
way more successful in stand-up com from
a financial perspective okay i've made
way more money doing stand-up comedy
than i ever made from exactly exactly
thank you so that's why a lot like when
he said to me like oh in the 80s when
you were you know big or whatever and
i'm like no no you don't understand like
because in the 80s the way i look at it
was i was a slave i wasn't making much
money i didn't get much play from girls
because i was shy and intimidated and
awkward so like the 80s to me were not
some great glory days you know what i
mean it was more like i was a slave kid
that was just basically trying to get
away from the abusers trying to get away
from the parents trying to get away from
everybody that was trying to hold me
down and then i ended up a drug addict
then i ended up in jail then i ended up
in rehab so it wasn't really until the
90s that i started even living my life
like quite honestly like 91 92 that's
when i started feeling like a human
being and actually caring about myself
and loving myself and wanting to like
self-heal and all of that kind of stuff
and so it was interesting because that
point on that my life started i think
you were still like
on some pretty hard drugs until at least
95 right no man oh no no
sober
wow okay i was sober in 89.
wow and how old are you then you're like
20 or something i was 18 18. and you've
got some correcting to do on wikipedia
oh dude wikipedia is whacked don't get
me started right i mean i i i no no no
no no no get me started
let me tell you about this okay let's
talk let's be real i've got i've got
some [ __ ] on wikipedia i'm on media
blackout do you know what media blackout
it means that there's actually people
out there that are working on a 24-hour
basis to discredit and defame me and
change the facts of life
so they're you know wikipedia is
supposed to be an open forum where
anybody user friendly can go in there
and edit whatever they want right which
leaves you open to the truth it also
leaves you open to lies right that's
what you would think
but if me or anybody on my team tries to
go into wikipedia you can try it right
now and you try to edit something
it'll stick for about two minutes and
then it goes back and reverts to
whatever the [ __ ] was that was there
okay then like if it's me and i try it
say like multiple times two or three
times all of a sudden i get a notice up
that says i'm blocked my ip address is
blocked for the next two years wow and
anybody that tries to even try to change
wikipedia no remember being on a cookie
you should be able to the way that that
whole program is set up the way that the
website works is it's a user-friendly
basis which means that anybody with a
computer and any you know basic
knowledge of html can get in there and
edit it and show the links that they
need to show to show the truth and like
it should all back up because somebody's
got to go through it and go like oh this
makes sense this points to this
but they have some kind of system on
mine maybe yours i don't know i mean i
don't know how truthful yours is they're
off you're i mean it's just like you
know it says i've been married twice and
i've actually never been married right
so that's fine are they allowed to do
that though but here's the thing
yeah good question right especially when
they're purposefully blocking your ip
address or anybody associated with you
so yeah wikimedia is the company that
owns wikipedia and we're probably going
to have to like send them some very
serious letters from our lawyers because
this is not acceptable they're out there
lying about me everything on women
like what's the malicious lie the
malicious lie is like you just said
there's you know they say that i wasn't
really sober
one of the things says that i went on
the today show in october and then two
months later i was arrested in louisiana
like
let me tell you something i was never
arrested in louisiana
right that was flash i was not arrested
members of my band were arrested
and a half a xanax pill
okay
not my xanax bill not my weed i wasn't
arrested let's just be real so the
bottom line is there's people out there
maliciously intentionally trying to make
me sound like a liar
trying to change my
credibility okay because obviously if
i'm lying about this or if i'm lying
about that then those really important
big stories that i told in my
documentary must not be true because
obviously i'm a liar all right you know
who's telling these lies or is just
anonymous it's connected to
the debunking of my truth so i put out a
documentary you know about the
documentary i mean i guess or maybe not
but i didn't know about it until i got
ready to meet you today and then i was
like wow you know so where's this
documentary available it's not anymore
it's not so what happened was i spent
1.3 million dollars making this film
uh we premiered at the director's guild
there was 700 people there sold out
audience
standing room only amazing incredible
and the night we get there we start the
film and it was streaming globally
because i was the first person actually
ever to do a live global streaming
vod premiere and people have paid to
pay-per-view right did was it successful
it would have been had we not gotten
hacked and pirated okay okay so as the
film started all of a sudden the thing
froze
and
people all over the world who paid money
to see the film could not see it because
there was an interruption of service
it's called a ddos server attack okay
okay so we got a ddos server attack that
shut down the film shut down the stream
they actually copied it they stole the
stream
they copied the script
and then they created a subsidiary
website that was like a copycat website
that went up literally live the moment
our stream came down
and they started selling tickets for
thirty dollars
versus us who was
charging twenty dollars for the ticket
so they're taking the same movie same
stream same script so it looks like the
same website they even pushed it up in
the google search so theirs was mine was
mytruthdoc.com theirs was
mytruthdocs.com
they put up a fake website the same
exact time that our premiere is out they
shut down yours did they direct all of
your traffic to their page correct
correct so they would have had to have
been able to uh
to edit your page as well but i guess
they hacked it yeah they hacked it they
stole the stream they copied the script
wow and they were able to build another
prototype of a website that looked
exactly like ourselves that went live
the moment that ours went down
by the
virginia and then somehow the media just
never talked about it
because the next day was kovid so nobody
wanted to talk about it and so i've
never been on any talk shows the news
won't have me on the i mean like that's
why i say media blackout because all the
mainstream media has prevented me from
coming forth and talking about this
story given that these hackers
uh
actually monetize it they took money
isn't it possible to follow that money
trail and and and get to these people
who committed the copyright yeah you'd
need a lot of expensive lawyers
and a lot of investigators were you able
to to
get any sense of of how many buys they
did well we can no i have no idea how
much these how many tickets they sold
for their
you know fake but i know that it was up
for three months
before we even knew about it i found it
by accident actually my my director the
guy who directed the film brian
herzlinger texts me one day and he goes
hey do you know about this you just you
just you just did a post for our movie
that goes to a different website and i'm
like what and he's like yeah and it was
like an accidental thing like i put my
truths instead of my truth by accident
and you click on it and it's an actual
website but it's not our website and
he's like yeah dude that's an entirely
different website that's not our website
i was like holy [ __ ] and it was uh
and they were selling
so that was multiple different websites
so there was that one that was the main
thing how they were pulling the money
out but the way they liquidated the
movie and made it worthless
was by putting it out for free all over
youtube so they put out about 200 free
links on youtube the first one got 250
000 views
before uh youtube would take it down and
we were sending them letters for weeks
and they wouldn't listen because we
didn't have like you know the exact
right trademark information or the exact
copyright information or whatever and
they like wanted everything by the book
before they would even listen to us that
this is our film even though i paid for
it even though it's my name on it i
produced it it's my lawyer hitting you
up but if you don't have the exact
paperwork they're not gonna listen that
makes me glad that we uh
got in business with that anti-piracy
company before putting out gnarly yeah
we spent like six thousand bucks to get
uh this anti-piracy company to like uh
you know stamp whatever redshift
anywhere my [ __ ] shows up yeah like it's
gonna be like
you know flat trademark type thing yeah
yeah that's gonna prevent the previous
from showing up on youtube i was so
naive man i had no idea i thought like
hey i found a foolproof way because look
i put out a book they edited my story i
put out a doc
a film on the lifetime network
that you know was a pretty good film
that i helped produce they edited and
changed the story even as far as like
changing the scenes to make it not what
it was supposed to be you know what i
mean so like everything kept getting
changed and edited how are you going to
get the truth out everybody kept saying
you got to get the truth out you got to
get the troop there fine
how do i do this so that nobody is
controlling the narrative
but me
right right well the only way that you
can possibly do that is to put it out in
a documentary format but even then
you've got to get your eno lawyers to
approve everything to make sure you
don't get sued right you can't put out
anything that's like above and beyond
and you have to work really really
really hard to prove that
everything is corroborated like there is
not one thing in that movie that wasn't
corroborated by like multiple people
that it sounded like that those were
some pretty
fiery allegation
right yeah but i'm confused i mean where
is it now the documentary was my truth
the rape of two quarries right again and
and even saying the word rape on youtube
i think uh gets you [ __ ]
have you not talked about it since then
i have not taught you this this is the
first time but you said that this
documentary is not available but so did
you ultimately get it all taken down
from youtube yeah so we got him finally
taken down but so 250 000 views at 20
dollars a pop how much money is that 250
000 views at 20.
5 million
more
50 million wait 250 fifty million i'm
bad enough 250 000 views
of pop
ah
it's 50 million
i think it's five it's five million
twenty divided by four
yeah it's uh because
divided by 250 though
it's a quarter million 250 times two is
five hundred thousand maybe i'm good and
then you add one zero because it's a
twenty six five million
i don't think so
maybe that's just one of the links and
then you know
whatever no that was definitely just one
of the links but the point is all
together it came out to like 80 million
dollars i mean it would have been it
would have been a lucrative business
play
it wasn't and we weren't doing it for
that you know at the end of the day we
just wanted to get the truth out but i
had bills i have to pay back people that
like a whole crew that was working on on
spec you know that was looking forward
to it doing well and getting paid and
then on top of it what we could have
done with the profits
would have been unbelievable i'm not
good at math either by the way so i
could totally be doing that
i don't even know but we should pull out
a calculator
somebody already has don't worry
somebody's sitting there like you're an
[ __ ] yeah on the comments
you're an [ __ ] you don't know how to
do math go bite yourself
it brings me back to the question i
wanted to ask which is for your prolific
film career and and you know the
staggering
like
success that you had in it
i would believe that it's your music
career that's been more financially uh
rewarding for you you're right
you're right yeah yeah because it's been
the last five years that my music
luckily blew up and again this was i
believe just an attempt to try and like
knock me down and make me look like a
jackass sorry for the expression
but yeah i mean because we did the today
show which was obviously a setup i mean
like every single media outlet at the
exact same moment the second we walked
off stage was like what was that what
was that bizarre strange performance you
know corey feldman really blew the you
know donkey or whatever like it was
terrible what was he thinking
and
it was all across the board everybody
had the exact same headline like you're
telling me that there's not one single
media outlet that saw it a little bit
differently or had a different
perspective or wrote maybe a few
different words no it was the exact same
language across the board at the same
time isn't that miraculous would you
piss off exactly so do you think about
pedophiles that are very powerful too
do you think that
um
in that case because there was so much
widespread uh
you know
coverage of this performance which was
critically panned like just the fact
that there was that much coverage do you
think that inadvertently it may go
through the roof right first of all it
was the most because of what they did it
backfired it was the most viewed
performance in the today show history
that's what she said so tara um tamara
sorry tamara hall
um
said it on live tv she goes this is the
most viewed performance in the
todayshow.com
ever boom right those are those
subscribe to the notion that there's no
such thing as bad publicity in this case
well there isn't as long as they're
writing about you or talking about you
then you're in good shape so that's why
what they're doing to me now is even
worse because they won't even have me on
to explain what's been going on they
won't even have me on to explain what
happened to my film we're talking about
a hundred million dollars worth of you
know liquid corruption that just
happened tax evasion who's who's paying
the taxes on all that money that went
through those fingertips i mean where's
all that advertising money all that you
know if you can't trace down the people
and the money for a copyright claim and
not only that but they were making dvds
they literally had dvds with the
packaging with the artwork with
everything and you're like presumably
presumably the documentary
you know
even though you didn't uh
make any money off of it right some
people made money off it and plenty of
people saw it so how is the documentary
critically reviewed oh amazingly okay
amazingly yeah i mean like anybody
that's giving an honest review of it
like okay so what happened was they
tried to act like it didn't happen at
all like i did actually read news
stories the next morning that said it
was all lie corey was scamming his fans
there was no movie
unfortunately what they didn't expect is
they didn't expect that i would have two
separate copies so we had the copy that
was streaming
uh for the whole world to see and then
we had a separate copy that was the
premiere copy of the dga so i actually
stopped the film 15 minutes in and said
look guys i don't know if i should
finish the movie because it's been
hacked online
and it's not really fair to all the
people who paid to not get to see the
movie at the same time as you so i was
thinking about not even playing the rest
of it at the premiere and coming back
and doing it a separate day once we got
it all worked out and it was actually a
bunch of actors who rushed the stage um
you know like roseanne arquette was one
of them and she was the most vocal and
she got to the front of the stage she
said corey you need to do this now she's
like do not back down she goes that's
what they want they want you to stop the
film they want you to not play it she
said but if you do this you're never
going to get all of us back here again
you're never going to get a whole
premiere full of people like it's never
going to happen
and i was like you know what she's right
and so because of that i continued the
film and i played the whole movie out
and so the next day you added in
rolling stone l.a times entertainment
weekly everybody reviewed the movie and
said it was a good movie and we did the
thing
you know
but then everybody that wasn't in the
room tried to say that the movie never
played there was no movie there was no
they're there it was a nothing burger
blah blah blah
so for people who are listening to this
and they're just dying to see this movie
are you really telling them that it's
not available i can't it can't because
number one i had to pull it i had to
pull it because of the safety of my my
life and my family you know there was
two attempts on my life leading up to
this which are documented in the movie
um the lapd for whatever reason will not
give us the video footage to prove that
i was actually attacked because people
tried to say that the attack never
happened that's the way they spun it the
lapd officer for whatever reason after
photo i mean i have video footage of
them photographing the the wound and and
sizing the the scar and the laceration
right they're literally like like sizing
it and taking pictures of it in the
hospital
they turned around and said there was no
puncture wound yeah and wow someone
tried to stab me in the back of the neck
and this side it was very tiny i mean it
was a god they they literally it was a
godsend i don't know how i can't explain
it but they missed so they didn't get
very far they just got like the very tip
of the knife into me so i thought it was
like maybe a needle because i couldn't
figure it out i remember the story being
that you thought it was somebody who was
trying to dermic needle yeah i didn't
know but then later on when i was
showing the jacket that i got stabbed
into the cops we saw a slit this big so
you know that it was a knife because
there was a slit in the jacket okay so
anyway so i went and filed a subpoena to
lapd for the freedom of information act
and said i know you guys have the
footage you showed me the footage you
can't see what they're doing but you can
easily see that they break into my car
and they reach in and they do something
right right give me that footage from my
documentary where did this attack take
place
in on ventura boulevard when and was it
and what was the night this is just
random you were there it wasn't random
they followed me they followed me from
where i was eating but it wasn't at like
uh the screening of your movie or no no
no no i was having dinner actually with
the director and my friend jamison
newlander who played the other frog
brother and we were actually discussing
and i was showing them what i call my
bible of evidence and i was showing them
everything telling them everything that
happened up to that point and why i felt
it was necessary to make this
documentary asking brian if he was
interested in you know being a part of
it and honestly he's sitting there
looking at me like is this guy lost his
mind like maybe he's gone crazy this is
like over he didn't believe any of it
and until he saw what happened to me
yeah because i left there that night and
i got followed and all this [ __ ] went
down and i ended up in the hospital the
next day so the the attack happened
while you were making the documentary
then we made the documentary before
right so then the documentary came out
you released it right since it's been
released were there other threats or
something that makes you want to
like retract that and not leave it out
yeah i mean first of all it's a constant
non-stop barrage on twitter on social
media um they're constantly gaslighting
me they're trying to accuse me of things
that i never did um you know basically
what happened was they sent some spies
into my life which are the girls that
were part of my angel tour a couple of
the musicians were not actual musicians
they were spies that were put into my
life to cause mayhem and destruction
they're called the honeypot crazy yeah
basically same kind of deal
so so these girls were put in there to
basically cause mayhem and disarray
and then when i fired them because of
the mayhem and disarray they turned
around and made false allegations about
me which were investigated by lapd and i
was cleared of those false allegations
yet they keep throwing them out there
and they keep adding names to the list
like oh there's like 10 girls who've
come forward there's no 10 girls but
they pretend that there's these fake
names so it's three girls that were sent
into my um tour bus basically and we
know who sent them there and they were
put there on purpose to make me look bad
and then make false allegations but then
they start adding names of like other
people that either we know some of the
names we don't even know who they are
we've never even met these people and
they just make these names and they and
they and they basically put a list out
there and they put it under false
allegations and it's tied to uh for a
while was actually tied to this girl
named mindy who is uh running to be a
politician who claimed that she knew all
this stuff about me like i'd never even
spent more than maybe like two nights
with her and nothing happened and like
basically she was there as a
date we went on a date but she was gonna
maybe be part of my angel thing and then
i just decided against it she just
didn't you know have the right vibe and
i wasn't into it and that never went
forward so she was like okay when were
these guys sent into your tour bus well
basically the tour bus itself i mean
this is i don't even know how much of
this i should say
i mean whatever that
it was a very nice one we hit a lot of
success right away we did the today show
it was very successful with the angels
and the angel band and all that but
unfortunately the girls that we used
they were good for like the one song
which was a fairly easy song but they
weren't capable of like learning 30
songs they just didn't have that kind of
skill so we needed more skilled girls
because they were spies no no no no no
just strictly professionally we needed
better skilled girls right we needed
girls that really knew what they were
doing because i have a very wide array
of music and you know we do everything
from like edm to rock to hip-hop i mean
it's kind of all over the map so you
really have to be very versatile as a
musician to be able to pull it all off
so because of that we felt like we
needed some you know kind of better
talent to be the touring talent
um and so what we did is we threw an
open audition
so open casting call and we did it over
facebook so i start getting hit up by
like girls from all over the country you
know oh yeah check out my reel check out
this check out that
so we brought in you know a girl this
girl like she said she was like a hippie
she was like a a gypsy rather not a
hippie but a gypsy traveling from like
town to town and she would just happen
to be in town and let me come by with my
audition
so she came over she auditioned we hired
her she had no place to stay so we let
her stay at our house
and then after she was there for a
little while she starts like saying that
you know she's a stripper which we
didn't know
and she wanted to like still make money
because we weren't letting her
strip because obviously we didn't want
that kind of a look around our branding
and she's like no no just let me do like
cam stuff from inside the house and i'm
like hell no what are you crazy i'm not
going to let that kind of thing be going
on in my house like are you nuts
so she didn't like the fact that i told
her no and i thought that was the reason
why she was doing all this terrible
stuff i had no idea that it was for a
darker reason which was that she was
sent there on purpose so we found that
out
based on the fact that she was making
phone calls and text messages to that
person
throughout the tour we found out that
the tour bus driver was his personal
tour bus driver we found out that we
were on his actual tour bus which we
paid for but yeah we got a really good
deal let's just say that much the way we
ended up on that bus is because they
made the best offer out of all the
different buses we were looking at what
i'm trying to get a sense of is with all
the craziness surrounding the movie and
and the uh
you know the
just the controversy and
and everything
does that just fuel the success of the
of the music
it would if people knew that the music
was coming out here's the problem right
now is we're having a very hard time
marketing this new album we've got this
beautiful box set and this beautiful new
album and a great new single but the
problem is when mainstream media isn't
supporting you
and you're not popping up everywhere
like when we were you know we did the
today show we had the top 40 song on the
billboard charts
and it was everywhere like people
magazine rolling stone billboard
everybody broke the story about corey's
new albums coming out so we announced we
put out a press release new album's
coming out nobody's picking it up it's
crickets so let's let's see the box they
don't support you how are you going to
get a hit right so it's all based on you
now stevo you're the
you're the lifeline so is this on
spotify this isn't finished yet so this
is this is just look at the artwork but
yeah wow and actually has the world's
first ever hologram
uh on a box set so we've never had this
kind of technology before in history but
i am the first artist i believe to pop
up in a hologram on top of my own box
and dance across the top of it so you're
gonna pop up here
you can open but the cds aren't there
yet because it's not finished actually
we get them tomorrow so if we've done
this interview one day later i could
have given you the cd wallet but you can
see some of the items inside
there's the 22 magazine which was
specially made just for this
wow wow and that features a lot of the
artists who are part of the box um from
don dawkin
to michael uh damien mickey thomas a lot
of 80s dudes because this box box that
basically covers from 1986 to 1994
plus we have a brand new album so the
brand new album is a sequel the first
album was called love left and the
sequel is called love left to army with
love so the first album came out in 1994
we started recording it actually the
very first song was while i was working
on lost boys living in my dad's
apartment and in the music video runaway
which is part of the box set and also
available for free on my youtube channel
right now
you can see the two guys that molested
me
dancing behind me in my dad's apartment
at 15 years old because those were my
friends those were the guys i was
hanging out how do they find the youtube
channel you can just go to corey feldman
youtube just type in you know corey
feldman channel on youtube youtube.com
corey feldman that's it yeah or corey
feldman two i think you have to write in
the two yeah and um
so you started your music
your band in 94. no i started in 86. so
as i was saying the very first video was
during while we were shooting lost boys
look we got these cool sunglasses
how many of the positions are the same
from the original well the great thing
about this is like we got in touch with
everybody so everybody so okay the very
first song i wrote was called runaway
ironically and it was about a
15-year-old kid who's getting abused at
home and is looking for some kind of
salvation so he goes and he runs away
and he gets on the streets and he gets
caught up in a sex trafficking ring
where they start feeding him crack now
this was all premonition because i had
not done drugs yet
wow i was an innocent kid i'm working on
lost boys
living in my dad's apartment and all of
a sudden boom
uh it all happened so literally i tried
to run away which was me getting
emancipated and then i got you know the
crack in my face and all that stuff so
it all kind of played out exactly the
way that i first saw it including having
the two pedophiles in the music video
with me dancing around in the living
room so it's really bizarre but you know
i felt like instead of running from it i
got to put it out there because that was
how it all started so this is a vinyl ep
and it's like a eight song teaser uh so
that came out about three four months
ago which that sold really well because
we did it as a fundraising thing where
like basically people had to buy them to
press them so we like sold all of them
in advance it was like a pre-sale
pre-order yeah yeah i love the artwork
it's a picture disc so it's actually
really badass the the disc itself is
beautiful and how um do people get
themselves this if they are interested
in any of the above they can go to my
website coreyfeldman.net and they can
buy whatever they want there there's
anything autographed on there if they
want it autographed we'll autograph i
want to get one i'm going to get one of
those autographs i look at you thank you
i appreciate this
he really does like
that means a lot to me he's clean and
sober nice he bought yes he bought weed
yesterday to support jaleel white
it smelled so good
i smoked it last night it was
great i'll give it a review yeah it's
fantastic did you micro dose too no i
just went straight so i had a pure
review mushrooms from jewelry i still
have them yeah i haven't used them yet
some guy on tour like just gave us these
like a shitload of magic mushrooms
they gave a hymn they're real
and scott
because you know i was like i don't this
guy's like naming off all these
constraints and i'm like isn't that
beautiful but scott's like why don't you
just eat all those right now like you
always expect me to do drugs you're busy
talking about drugs no time for
promotion
dotnet yes coreyfeldman.net is where you
get all things corey feldman including
the love returns ep
and the love left 2.1 box set which
features both my brand new album love
left 2 army with love and the remix
remaster of the original album and 18
never released songs from 1986 to 1994
and
four hours worth of video footage
including a brand new documentary not
this documentary that we were talking
about but a music documentary which is
kind of like more like
music which shows how it all started
with my music career when i started
recording when i started performing when
like how it all got to this point yeah
and then also the making of the actual
box set and the new album so it's pretty
cool
so that's a very comprehensive box set
which covers your entire music career
not entire only 86 to 94.
so that's the whole idea is the starting
the beginning of the matter so it's like
an 80s
rolling stones the first one exactly
exactly and then the brand new album so
that brings it up to speed but
everything in between all five albums
that happen in between are not
represented okay yeah and are you
touring uh we plan to we hope to but i
need to get a new book you need to get a
new tour bus a new tour but
um i i sure could i i went the rv route
not like the traditional tour bus okay
okay i got i did that too we did that on
one of our tours did you consider that a
mistake um that was my first full bus
tour yeah so that was it for no wait
that was my second full bus tour i'm
lying i did one on the last truth
movement tour uh for the last truth
movement album we had a big bus that was
beautiful and that was very nice and
very convenient but that said i did a
really nice rv tour as i think the
second angelic tourist like the mini
tour um and we got like this like 35
foot winnie type thing
but it was like it had like the
extenders that come out
yeah and it was pretty dope too because
the way that it was outfitted like the
extender would pop out and like when you
obviously you had to do that when you
were only parked like you couldn't do
that while you were driving but the
thing is that like when it popped when
it went back in it shut off a wall and
inside those walls there were sleepers
so like it was great if you had it open
because you had a little area to chill
but as soon as it closed you were
basically locked in and you couldn't get
out of your sleeper until like we opened
it back up again which means if there
was like a bad accident that's like
super dangerous please tell me that's
not the next one talk about a fire
hazard yeah
i did way better by it bro
i hooked you up bro i i'll like come
into steve's like room in the rv and
he's looking at like a rv video that has
like 40 views he's like dude look at
this thing and he's like showing
everybody yeah it's he's obsessed was it
cool though it's very [ __ ] cool
it's cool
trains you know
no but you know look if you know if you
got like a shower you're doing really
good i mean i don't know if you got like
you know a little kitchenette the one i
got has a dishwasher a washer dryer
that's what i'm talking about
up to nine people
that's what i'm saying you'll go check
out the rv's and he knows more about it
than the people and the best part is you
don't have to pay the damn driver i mean
especially if they're crooked and
they're there to just cause problems
we're hiring a driver anyway so you are
yeah we won't be paying a driver no i
wouldn't i would see when we were doing
our mini tour i was driving part of the
time
and that's actually how i got pulled
over and the whole louisiana thing
happened
see if it had been a bus driver
then they wouldn't have even been able
to put my name in the paper but because
i was the one that got pulled over
and then we had to take it down to the
police station because i was supposedly
driving on a suspended license which i
wasn't aware of because we just rented
the damn thing and used my own insurance
and my own driver's license like a week
and a half before but somehow like i
guess i forgot to pay something and it
popped up right during that little
period of time so all of a sudden now i
was like whoops bad timing i guess my
license is suspended and this is how i
found out so we get down to the police
station they couldn't charge me with
anything because i didn't do anything
wrong other than driving with a
suspended license which quite honestly
should have just been a warning because
it was within 30 days and within 30 days
it's supposed to technically be a
warning louisiana that will nullify the
insurance said now you're driving
without insurance and i think there's
registration issues as well so like but
they didn't they didn't say all that
yeah and like i said i was never
arrested so they basically looked at it
and they went yeah he's right this is
probably more than we should do so
instead let's just go sell this story to
the press and tell everybody he got
arrested for drugs
press is good or it can be that was not
good price and wikipedia can suck my
you know what good
um so so we're hoping to get back on
tour soon yes that would be great
but there are no dates as as yet not yet
and the box set is uh available for
pre-order it's available for pre-order
right now coreyfeldman.net and you can
come i would love if you guys can make
it out to my record release party
because the album actually comes out and
the box that comes out on january 12th
22. we're on tour we'll be on the road
yeah we're on twitter but dude i would
love that yeah i would absolutely love
that what are you doing what are you
doing it's comedy tour yeah that's cool
we leave that for kalamazoo yeah leave
that day for kalamazoo really is there a
way you can push it back
we got kalamazoo we got on the 13th so
we got to fly out the day before and is
that the place where they all use um
those little things that go dinking
yeah yeah
but uh but dude i i would absolutely
love to support you and i particularly
you know i have a soft spot in my heart
for
for anybody who's known for one thing
who has ventured out into another thing
and and been successful
here's the thing you know we can't
control the world we can't control what
happens so all we can do is try our best
to like reinvent ourselves and try and
keep up with the joneses right sure and
especially when they try to put you in
that box you know they love to put you
in that box and say this is who this is
and this is how they're gonna always be
and that's the way it is and it's like
no man i'm a human being and i evolve
you evolve we all evolve right we have
to have the ability and the freedom to
evolve from what i understand too your
music has like a really dedicated like
hardcore fan base absolutely yeah yeah
my fans love this stuff and and you know
what i mean i'm very grateful and very
like i love my fans i love them to death
they are everything to me but i do it
because i love it you know at the end of
the day it's a passion
and i have really good taste in music
i'm friends with some of the greatest
rock stars and entertainers in history
which means basically i try to soak up
everything i can through those
relationships i go into the studio with
them i learn from them and i try to you
know bring that into my work so i take
my work very seriously when it comes to
music as you said but i don't take
myself too seriously because why that's
the way
you mentioned you they were on instagram
live so so yeah so what's your instagram
uh it's
22. c dog 22. i'm going to double g man
c d o double g you know what c
22 that's right snoop dogg who's on the
go for it single you know my last single
word
so is there anything else that we can
play we got your social media we got
here yeah twitter which has been
hijacked by thieves so you know it looks
very hackable it seems like it has been
in the past now
oh yeah now that we got jack dorsey out
everything's gonna change right
right we'll see no it's not about
hackable it's about there's stuff like i
said this stuff is bigger than we all
like to think and there are there are
powers that be that are in control of
our lives beyond what we would like to
believe
and and it is very abundantly clear when
you are on a platform like twitter
because they do things like they allow
people who are blocked from me to jump
into my thread into my timeline and post
something there like a link to some bs
article that's not true or you know full
of lies so how do they do that how are
they allowed to do that and then when i
report them instead of them getting
taken down i get a letter back that says
we do not see how they have broken any
of our twitter safety violations and
you're like really
what kind of twitter safety violations
do you have to do to actually get taken
down so we won't promote your twitter
yeah no it's great okay forget about the
twitter we like instagram it's seeddog22
that's right all things kroy and feldman
live at coreyfeldman.net
you got it and you can still buy my
burnt ears you know i've got these like
burnt ears from the movie stand by me we
made like a replica and it's available
at
cfnftme.com so you can get that too so
there's an nft of burnt ears yeah yeah
yeah we did an nft of mine
here from stand by me we did like a
whole hybrid auction thing and then well
lo and behold that got hacked and uh
unfortunately they froze the bid button
for 12 hours making it impossible for
the number to go up and we got stuck
with a thirty seven hundred dollar sale
i've one at one east one uh that would
be about one eight yeah yeah yeah i did
i didn't an nfc and i only got one
eighth
yeah but was yours because of uh
corruption and scandal or was it because
it really i was like i wish i could say
it went on for one eighth and then that
guy someone bought it and then someone
else up bid like 1.101
or you know like it was like that yeah
no no ours was like really hot and heavy
like everybody was bidding for the first
12 hours and then all of a sudden it
just stuck and it wasn't changing and
i'm like that doesn't seem right so i
like hit the people up who are running
it and they're like oh yeah it's a blunt
blunt brute force attack uh where i
guess they had made eight thousand
attempts to get into the server so that
they could shut it down entirely but
they weren't able to do that they were
only able to freeze the bid button
preventing people from bidding it's
awesome
that's the plan and more nfts are
available are you on openc
i i don't know about open c but is that
is that your gallery well that's where
yeah that's where we were running it
through but right now we only have two
nfts we've only made two so far under my
deal with cosmic wire we're supposed to
be making a lot more we'll see what
happens fingers crossed everything looks
like the way to find out about that is
to follow you on instagram which is
cdawg22 absolutely or coreyfeldman.net
because you can always find out
everything corey at corey feldman i love
it man yeah dude thank you brother oh
yeah thank you i appreciate your support
that was amazing dude yeah
thanks guys
did i say we had bombshells or what i
mean dude
like there's a lot there's a lot of
hacking going on
there was uh a lot of conspiracies going
on
and um
it was entertaining so thank you guys
for sticking around to the very end you
know i love the street team
and uh
[ __ ] man it's december 30th
so i hope everybody has a safe and happy
new year yeah dude